[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren es
ist viertel nach acht herzlich
willkommen zu viertel nach acht freuen
sich auf rund eine gute stunde
spannenden und witzigen talk und ich
habe ganz tolle gäste hier im studio und
beginne mit einer
medizinjournalistin mit einer
buchautorin mit einer dame die unter
anderem den bestseller vergiss alzheimer
verdacht demenz geschrieben hat mit
einer dame die sich selbst bezeichnet
als jemanden der ihn jetzt kommt das
zitat talkrunden engagiert mitdiskutiert
herzlich willkommen cornelia stolze das
thema von frau stolzer heute abend affen
pocken alles nur affentheater und
panikmache ich begrüße ganz herzlich
einen der besten kenner der berliner
politikszene des berliner
politikbetriebs er war jahrelang
kolumnist des stern dort auch mitglied
der chefredaktion die financial times
nannte ihn einen der einflussreichsten
kommentatoren der welt herzlich
willkommen hans ulrich jörges und das
thema von hans ulrich jörges heute abend
wir brauchen einen corona
untersuchungsausschuss ja das wird jetzt
langsam zeit lieber herr jörges er ist
sozialdemokrat im einstigen muss man ja
schon sagen im einstigen spd stammland
nordrhein-westfalen er war dort in der
landeshauptstadt auch oberbürgermeister
aber er sorgte auch jüngst mit einem
umstrittenen beitrag zu kriegsverbrechen
in der ukraine ordentlich für zunder und
kritik herzlich willkommen thomas keidel
und ich habs gerade angedeutet wie soll
es anders sein bei thomas geisel ist das
entscheiden und das spannende thema
heute abend der ukraine krieg und die
these die herr geissens mitgebracht hat
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine sind
unnötig und gefährlich das wird
sicherlich eine ganz ganz spannende
diskussion und dann nicht zuletzt möchte
ich ganz herzlich berlins fleißigsten
abgeordneten begrüßen er war der
fleißigste abgeordnete und die
mittelmäßigkeit der hauptstadt die
treibt ihn immer wieder quasi zur
weißglut er war in der fdp ist jetzt bei
den freien wählern und hat in der korona
pandemie eine eigene gewerkschaft
gegründet gegründet herzlich willkommen
marcel luthe und das thema dass marcel
ute heute besonders umtreibt das ist die
chaos wahl in berlin vom vergangenen
september
diese chaos war sagt marcel ute die
grenzt an betrug herzlich willkommen das
wird eine ganz spannende runde mein name
ist jan schäfer und nicht nur der
bundeswahlleiter der sich heute zu
dieser chaos wahl in berlin geäußert hat
war ein mann des tages nein auch karl
lauterbach hat heute einmal mehr für
furore gesorgt es geht um das thema
affen brocken lauschen sie selbst
kernbestandteil ist dass diejenigen die
infiziert sind sich für mindestens 21
tage isolieren sollen das soll es an
isolations anordnung geben für
mindestens 21 tage ergeben so soll es
eine strenge empfehlung eine dringende
empfehlung für die
kontaktpersonen geben die unmittelbaren
kontaktpersonen und er wird gleich aus
führen wir das genau ist für ebenfalls
21 tage so dass wir mit isolation und
quarantäne von mindestens 21 tage das
früher ausbruchsgeschehen in den griff
bekommen für
ja vor stolzen war das jetzt der
bundesgesundheitsminister oder war das
wieder der bundes bedenkenträger karl
lauterbach
in diese rolle hat er natürlich schon
und ich habe auch das gefühl dass herr
lauterbach in dieser situation angst
ängste schürt und bisschen panikmache
betreibt es ist einerseits verständlich
dass alle welt aufrecht wenn wieder von
einem neuen virus die rede ist und dass
man damit sofort natürlich verknüpft oh
gott das wird ja wohl nicht hoffentlich
jetzt wieder so losgehen wie mit corona
aber man muss sich klarmachen dass das
in diesem fall ein ganz anderer typ von
virus ist ganz andere übertragungswege
ganz andere infektiosität ganz andere
auch sagen wir mal
auswirkungen von erkrankungen und das wo
sich infektionsketten sehr viel
schneller stoppen lassen weil eben die
übertragungswege anders sind und wenn
man jetzt einige fälle in verschiedenen
ländern aufgefunden hat heißt das noch
lange nicht dass eine pandemie ist und
dass man jetzt da irgendwie wieder
anfangen muss mit was weiß ich lobbach
uns oder ähnlichen geschichten
ich finde in den sagen wir in den
interviews vermittelt herr lauterbach
leider teilweise einen merkwürdigen
eindruck auch von diesem virus und sagt
ja einerseits dieses virus ist bekannt
es ist nicht so schlimm und andererseits
sagt er aber ja wir wissen aber nicht
wie sich das virus verhalten wird und ob
das dann sozusagen zu einem menschen
virus wird denn wir müssen uns klar
machen eigentlich ist es ein virus das
hauptsächlich tiere befällt in der die
der eigentliche 14 nagetiere soweit man
weiß ja teilweise können auch affen sich
infizieren und über affen kann es sein
dass dann eben auch menschen sich
infizieren aber weil der mensch
eigentlich nicht der richtige ort ist
für die infektion kann sich das virus
auch gar nicht so gut übertragen also
hans ulrich jörges affentheater um die
affen pocken mein eindruck ist dass ist
heute bestätigt worden durch lauterbach
er sucht eine möglichkeit eine brücke zu
schaffen zwischen corona und corona im
herbst also das ist ja jetzt erst mal
sendepause also erst nicht mehr
eingeladen das jetzt im herren talkshows
und er hat nichts mehr zu erzählen er
hat vorläufig nichts zu warnen er hat
das killervirus angekündigt für den
herbst werde darüber gehen kann er nicht
mehr es gibt nichts anderes als killer
virus und dieses alles die ängste davor
wieder zu beleben indem er jetzt über
die affen pocken redet und wieder
quarantäne verhängt und so weiter fehlt
nur noch dass an der masken pflicht
verhängt die macht aber da glaube ich
gar kein sehr nicht kann man ja
denke ich mir alle berliner wäre es
jetzt wieder mit herrn wiler das ist das
alte gespann was wieder auftritt und
dann sage ich nach lauterbach lasst uns
in ruhe
herr geisel ich weise diese parteifreund
ja ich weiß auch nicht ob das jetzt
personalisieren sollte auf herrn
lauterbach ich was mich ärgert an der
ganzen geschichte ist sie sagen zu recht
ist offenbar ein vergleichsweise
harmloses virus die verläufe sind nicht
sonderlich schwer die infektionsgefahr
ist beherrschbar und was mich ärgert ich
meine krankheit gehört ein stück weit
zur conditio humana wir haben uns
irgendwie in zeiten von corona an
gewohnt dass niemand mehr krank werden
darf also ich würde mal sagen wenn das
eine spare krankheit ist dann sollte man
da jetzt nicht auf panik modus schalten
sondern soll den leuten sagen es gibt
keinen anlass sich übermäßig große
sorgen zu machen wer angst davor hat
neben sollte gesagt wird wie er sich
schützen kann und dann braucht man da
ansonsten nicht mehr an wieder jeden tag
im fernsehen auftreten zu lassen und
herr lauterbach sollte sich um ein drama
baut ihr parteifreund lauterbach so wie
es hans ulrich jörges gerade gesagt hat
der sich eine brücke bis zum herbst
braucht er diese panik eigentlich als
modus überhaupt politik machen zu können
wer sündigt zu wenig ob er ist
gewissermaßen
persönlich benötigt ich weiß dass karl
lauterbach in der gesundheitspolitik
eine ganze reihe vernünftiger positionen
besetzt in der gesundheitspolitik etwa
was die krankenversicherung was die
bürgerversicherung angeht da sind
position die mir gut gefallen bei carlo
und diese panik um pandemien ich glaube
das sollte mal ein bisschen nach hinten
schieben da haben sich die themen
vorknöpfen die ihm eigentlich in der
vergangenheit auch immer schöner richtig
solle doch mal was sagen zur
krebsbekämpfung soll auch mal was sagen
zur neuen finanzierung der krankenkassen
solle mal was sagen was die menschen
wirklich
beschäftigt an krankheiten und annan
finanzdruck auf ihrem portemonnaie dass
krankheiten angeht und was die
auslastung von kliniken angeht und die
beschäftigung von pflegepersonal unserer
sitzung viele themen gehen aber er redet
davon ihre messer geführt er ist ja fast
nicht im ministerium nach allem was man
hört erschwert ständig draußen rum und
wir können ja jetzt schon wetten
eingehen dass wir jetzt alle 14 tage
eine affen brocken pressekonferenz
halten wird mit herrn wähler und die
neuesten zahlen veröffentlichen heute
steht haben die regierung musste er die
muss er gar nicht verkünden wie kaum ein
staatssekretär volk oder herr wieder
alle ja jemand dagegen dass das so kommt
hinein und er selber machen marcel
unterhalten sie auch dagegen oder
glauben sie dass es genau so kommt eins
ist also eher lauterbach muss das auch
selbst verkünden denn das problem glaube
ich und deswegen brauche auch solche
sachen er braucht diese aufregung diese
dramatik wenn man sich mal dann guckt wo
er laut aber sozusagen parlaments
historisch herkommt ich erinnere mich
immer an diesen lustigen mann der
erklärt hat dass man sein essen nicht so
stark salzen soll irgendetwas jeden fall
ordentlich zu als 70 menschen das den
menschen vorschrift dann will ich
wahrgenommen werden kann wie ich
irgendwie ein bisschen wichtig bin und
das versucht er jetzt gerade meines
erachtens ganz deutlich noch einmal in
der tat zur frage übertragungswege ich
habe sehr grafisch etwas gesagt es ist
einfach also ein vollkommener kokolores
und ich glaube es langsam einfach an dem
punkt an dem man merkt dass er ja
irgendwie egal wie weit er da noch
bewegung rein bringt nicht mehr nochmal
einmal hoch drehen kann und das führt zu
einem überdrehen und dieses überdrehen
merken wir glaube ich gerade bei dieser
panikmache er macht sich nur noch
lächerlich ich glaube auch dass man
natürlich auch sagen jetzt mit diesem
thema viren mit dem thema drohende
pandemie ausbreitung also es wird ja
schon so ein bisschen gezeichnet als
könnte sich das jetzt noch ganz stark
ausbreiten wenn man jetzt keine
drastischen maßnahmen ergreift also das
hört man schon auch raus und
man kann damit sozusagen auch eine eine
stimmung natürlich schaffen in der
bevölkerung und vielleicht das ist jetzt
aber sozusagen spekulation ist es kein
zufall dass gerade diese woche sich auch
herr lauterbach mit vielen anderen
experten wo es um globale pandemie geht
also globale infektionserkrankungen
treffen sich in genf zur welt
gesundheits versammlungen bh und da geht
es unter anderem auch darum der whu
größere befugnisse irgendwie zu erteilen
um dann sozusagen vorgaben für die für
viele viele länder auf der welt zu
machen wie man dann mit infektions
ausbrüchen umgehen soll und das kann
natürlich schon auch sozusagen noch mal
rückenwind für diese ganze thematik
geben also ich halte herrn lauterbach
weniger also er ist in meinen augen
weniger ein mediziner dem es um
gesundheit und patienten um gesundheit
einer ganzen bevölkerung geht sondern er
ist ein politiker der genau weiß welche
knöpfe man drücken muss um sozusagen
sich in den vordergrund zu spielen und
bestimmte themen zu setzen und dann auch
politisch was dran doch viel
interessantere themen mit denen er sich
in den vordergrund spielen können ich
glaube die leute haben sind dieser punkt
orie und er sind dem
thema pandemie etwas über 30 ich kann
mir nicht vorstellen dass er damit
wirklich brownlee points gibt es gibt
viele sondern trifft bei dem thema
wenn es zutrifft was gegenwärtig stand
der erkenntnis ist es ist kein besonders
bedrohliches virus infektionsgefahr ist
begrenzt und verläufe sind milde in der
regel und ich sage mal der kreis der
gefährdeten ist ja auch überschaubar
dann würde ich sagen ich glaube die
leute werden sagen da wird panik gemacht
wird sind wir haben genug davon wir
haben jetzt zwei jahre mit einer
pandemie gelebt und ihre haltung mit
ihrem unter gehört haben will ich sagen
ich glaube nicht dass es das man sich
als politiker damit beliebt machen kann
ich glaube nicht mehr dass sich europa
sieht das ja auch im iran wie sie
anfragen karl lauterbach war ja über
monate der beliebteste politiker
deutschlands und im wöchentlichen insel
ranking für bild stürzt er geradezu
absurd ist
das was er macht eigentlich jetzt geht
das motorkonzept vergleich zu dass wir
nicht aussprechen müssen uns internet
gucken dann sieht man was die leute von
ihm halten die kritiker von ihm halten
kann ich nur vorsichtig sagen wir halten
ihn für für nicht stabil für nicht
gesund muss mal so auszudrücken er ist
genauso abgestürzt übrigens wieder
kanzler und ich glaube dass lauterbach
dass auch er kennt und keine pause was
seine eigene person angeht
inszenieren will dass man mal irgendwie
ein zwei monate nichts von ihm hört weil
es auch nichts zu berichten gibt und er
bleibt mein ministerium und arbeitet an
der sache ich glaube er hat ein bisschen
angst davor dass der kanzler nach den
schlechten wahlergebnissen der spd
versucht sein könnte die
verteidigungsministerin und ihn
auszuwechseln weil sie beide reif sind
dafür ob scholz dafür den mumm hat und
die weitsicht das möchte ich bezweifeln
aber gut wäre es eigentlich müsste er
sich doch freuen dass es mit frau
lambrecht noch jemanden im kabinett gibt
die eigentlich noch den stärker davor
steht entlassen zu werden als karl
lauterbach oder nicht
ich glaube
das ist das ist die situation mit denen
mit den mäusen die da irgendwie
versuchen aus dem loch zu kommen die
eine krabbelt auf die andere drauf das
nützt ja dann letztlich keiner von
beiden ich glaube nicht dass es darum
geht dass irgendjemand da noch
schlechter ist sondern das kernproblem
von lauterbach ist eben halt das eben
einerseits das thema fehlt das genug
andere themen da liegen sie als
richtiger weise angesprochen
aber das problem das er hat ist dass die
probleme die neu entstanden sind nehmen
wir eben halt die vielzahl von
ausgefallenen operationen zu meiden
nehmen wir die weitere überlastung des
personals im gesundheitswesen dass eine
unmittelbare folge der einrichtungs
bezogener nachweispflicht ist weil viele
hundert kräfte in jeder stadt in jedem
bundesland jeweils ausfallen und dadurch
also die versorgungslage noch schlechter
wird operationen verschoben werden
müssen auch natürlich in der ganzen lock
down phase für die lauterbach ja auch
mitverantwortlich war weil teil dieser
koalition
in dieser ganzen locker und phase was
alleine an dialyse zum beispiel
ausgefallen ist verschoben werden musste
was an notwendigen eingriffe nicht hat
es damals im parlament angesprochen an
herzoperationen für kranken und musste
die verstorben sind da brauchen wir eine
evaluation halte und das ist glaube ich
auch ein sehr sehr gutes stichwort karl
lauterbach war ja nicht nur teil der
letzten bundesregierung der großen
koalition aber gefühlt eigentlich schon
der heimliche gesundheitsminister hat ja
auch jens spahn mit allen seinen
forderungen und den studien die ja immer
wieder auch dann nachts gelesen hat und
am morgen getwittert hat vor sich
hergetrieben hans ulrich jörges da
kommen wir zur these von ihnen was genau
bedeutet das für den bundes irgendeiner
class genau bedeutet das eigentlich
haben alle reliquien neue skandale aus
dem schattenreich von corona
aufgeschreckt zum einen haben wir
erfahren dass der steuerzahler um
ungefähr eine milliarde euro erleichtert
worden ist durch falsche abrechnungen
von corona testzentren privaten corona
des zentren eine milliarde nächste
selbstbedienungs fall in diesem großen
schattenreich von corona das zweite es
sind in berlin
185000 impfstoffdosen vernichtet worden
deren
haltbarkeitsdatum überschritten war in
hamburg waren es 100.000 da frage ich
mich kann man das nicht rechtzeitig
vorher erkennen dass man sich diesem
enddatum nähert und dann diese
impfstoffe wenn sie hier nicht gebraucht
werden an länder weitergibt die sie
brauchen und sei es nordkorea die nun
zugeben dass sie ein problem haben aber
keine impfstoffe warum kann man das
nicht tun warum vernichtet man die ich
glaube es ist jetzt wirklich zeit dass
wir in dieser relativen ruhe die wir
jetzt haben was bewohner angeht einen
bundestags untersuchungsausschuss
einsetzen der die gesamte corona politik
der letzten zwei jahre untersucht für
mich sind alle wichtigen fragen nämlich
unbeantwortet ich habe die mal
aufgeschrieben ist sie ganz schnell vor
welche fragen das sind warum war das
gesundheitssystem nicht vorbereitet auf
die pandemie es gab mal zu einer
trockenübung vom rk aida ist das
ergebnis sehr alarmierend in alle fächer
aller bundestagsabgeordneten gelegt
worden cmt landesregierung wurden
informiert es ist vorbei gerauscht
niemand hat es gelesen warum wurden die
alten und pflegeheime anfangs nicht
geschützt was ist kindern durch
quarantäne und schulschließungen angetan
worden was taugen masken wirklich wovor
schützen impfungen und wen gefährden sie
welche nebenwirkungen haben impfungen
wer hat die impfkampagne des bundes
gegen die wand gefahren ist die
impfpflicht mit dem grundgesetz
vereinbar durften millionen von
ungeimpften aber täglich getesteten
durch zweig vom leben ausgeschlossen
werden ist das robert-koch-institut
überfordert und schließlich wer hat sich
an corona eine goldene nase verdient und
die ergebnisse einer solchen
untersuchungsausschusses müssen ja nach
vorne gewendet werden falls es wieder
soweit kommt im herbst und winter das
ein anderes virus unterwegs ist dann
müssen schlussfolgerungen aus
untersuchungen bezogen werden auch um
solchen wie soll ich sagen solche news
canons wie karl lauterbach ein paar
haltbaren regel in die füsse zu schlagen
braustolz angenommen sie sind jetzt im
bundestag und wer dann während dann
mitglied dieses untersuchungsausschusses
den hans ulrich jörges grad nochmal mit
wirklich nachdruck ja auch gefordert hat
von dem wir eigentlich auch gehört haben
er solle com christian lindner hat dass
er im wahlkampf gesagt nun will man in
der ampelkoalition davon gar nicht so
viel wissen aber angenommen sie saßen in
diesem ausschuss und müssten zu einem
urteil kommen schlechter mutter von aus
dem was sie an erfahrung da auch schon
mitbringt wie würde ihr urteil ausfallen
wie die maßnahmen insgesamt waren also
als wäre ich jetzt schon am ende dieser
analyse wenn sie also ich glaube dass
sehr viele maßnahmen überhaupt nicht sie
für zielführend waren dass sie
übergriffig waren dass sie
gegen ja recht geltendes recht verstoßen
haben das auch vieles vernachlässigt
wurde zum beispiel für hätte man von
anfang an überhaupt erstmal daten fakten
gewinnen müssen darüber wie bedrohlich
ist denn überhaupt die situation und das
hätte man problemlos auch zu sehr
vertretbaren
eurobeträgen machen können aber man hat
sich schlichtweg geweigert das zu tun
und vieles war einfach überhaupt nicht
schlüssig widersprach jeglicher logik
und ich muss sagen da bin ich eigentlich
ehrlich gesagt auch ein gewisser weise
entsetzt in einem land wie unserem dass
das geschehen kann bei so vielen
eigentlich klugen menschen bei einem
rechtssystem wo man eigentlich denken
müsste das schützt uns vor solchen
übergriffen und dass das alles ist da
sehr ins wanken geraten also ich finde
also ich fürchte das wäre eine ganz
katastrophale bilanz thomas kaiser sie
haben ja früh vor den vor den folgen
eigentlich eines lockt downs gewahrt und
haben schon anfang 20 21 gesagt läuft
dieser lockdown 20 errichtet naja aber
geht die wahl im zweiten block da auch
noch mal sehr präsent mit ihren mit
ihren aussagen und haben ja auch da
gesagt dass dieser lockdown
offensichtlich unnötig und auch
verfassungswidrig ist fühlen sie sich
bestätigt es sein ich glaube das ist ein
großer fehler war ich finde alle fragen
herr jörges wie sie der aufwerfen sind
absolut relevant und sollten auch
gegenstand eines solchen
untersuchungsausschusses sein ich glaube
besonders ich bin ja nun vater von fünf
kindern
und was ich wirklich bemerkenswert fand
ich meine smiley gelernt haben wir alles
ein liebes die sind zwischen 11 und 25
na ja gut aber ich mach euch bringen wir
euch gehen und eine mit 14 also ich sag
mal mädchen in der pubertät wollen
anfangen leben und co absoluter sagen es
war ja nun von anfang an eine sehr sehr
schnell klar dass dieses virus extrem
alters dem ist diskriminierend unterwegs
ist und dass man keinen gedanken darauf
verschwendet hat wie man vielleicht die
gefährdeten gruppen gezielt schützen
kann und diejenigen die eigentlich
nichts zu befürchten haben so normal wie
möglich leben das weiterleben lassen
kann des glaubens in der tat da haben
wir uns an den kindern wirklich
versündigt ich habe hier mal einfach das
gedankenexperiment in den raum gestellt
was den gewesen wäre wenn es genau
umgekehrt gewesen wäre wenn nur die
jungen betroffen gewesen wären dann
hätte man wahrscheinlich den industrie
club in düsseldorf nicht geschlagen
haben dass man alle haben das war nicht
in ordnung weil man hat diesen
forderungen beziehungsweise auch mit
diesen aussagen die getätigt haben im
lok 23 20 in london 21 eigentlich in
ihrer partei und gerade auch bei karl
lauterbach gar kein gehirn könnt also
ich sage mal morgens sagen die der
zeitgeist war in der tat anders es war
eine allgemeine panik was mich auch
überrascht hatte ja manchmal den
eindruck die politik vermittelt den
eindruck der staat habe quasi eine
garantenpflicht dafür übernommen dass
niemand mehr krank wird ich habe immer
gesagt ein bisschen eigenverantwortung
insbesondere wenn impfstoff da ist und
genügend impfstoff dass jeder davon
gebrauch machen kann und wenn jeder die
regeln kennt mit denen er sich schützen
kann also diese regeln dann bin ich
schon der meinung dann muss der staat
eigentlich nicht weiter tätig sein dann
muss man oder muss man jedenfalls
verhalten ist beschränken die regeln den
regelungen massiv zurückfahren dann kann
man ein stück weit jedenfalls solange
das gesundheitswesen nicht insgesamt
gefährdet ist und ich glaube auch dass
wärme gegenstand einer solchen der suche
nach meiner kenntnis auch wenn es immer
wieder an die wand gemalt wurde war das
gesundheitswesen in wahrheit nie
gefährdet wir hatten als ich noch
oberbürgermeisterwahl in düsseldorf
jeden tag die wasserstandsmeldungen über
freie kapazitäten frei
intensivmedizinische kapazitäten in den
krankenhäusern der war nie auch nur wie
soll man sagen entfernt irgendein
notstand sind erst mal sagen dass also
die gefahr bestand nicht und das blieb
nach meinem dafürhalten
praktisch unberührt hat sich verzogen
hatte nachdem auch gerade was thomas
kaiser gesagt hat hat sich eigentlich
aus ihrer sicht und das ist glaube ich
für einen liberalen immer dann im moment
wo man noch mal innehalten muss hat sich
aus ihrer sicht eigentlich der anspruch
der bundesbürger nach dieser panne an
den start noch mal wieder verstärkt also
dieser fürsorgende start dieser start
der meinte alles regeln zu müssen bis
ins mikro detail eigentlich sie hatten
es zwei jahre begleitet und viele fanden
das ja irgendwie gar nicht so schlecht
glauben sie dass das
nachwirkende folgen hat das das
bleibende schäden hinterlässt also es
gibt den schönen satz das problem des
liberalismus in deutschland ist es
menschen mit ihrer freiheit oftmals
nicht so viel anzufangen wissen da merkt
man das gilt in der tat nach wie vor
auch bei vielen menschen gerade dann
wenn sie eben halt nicht richtig
informiert werden ich bin nicht der
auffassung dass ist und zwar so ein
anderes noch mal es entspricht dem
leitbild des grundgesetzes dass ich
selbst darüber bestimmen wie ich leben
möchte das ist genau die lehre die der
parlamentarische rat gezogen hat als
buch als das klare bild was wir
eigentlich als neuen staatsbürger
wollten nicht mehr der staat der sich um
dich kümmert sondern du selbst der duh
teilnimmst an diesen demokratischen
staatswesen dir selbst eine meinung
bildet dich selbst einbringt und so
weiter und so fort das ist so dumm
geführt worden in der panini ist
komplett umgedreht worden genau und zwar
nicht paternalistisch kümmern sondern
absolut übergriffig denn es geht ein
staatswesen im übrigen eines das so
versagt hat wie dieses überhaupt nichts
an ob ich krank werde oder nicht es ist
meine sache wie ich leben möchte und
wenn ich barfuß durch den schnee laufen
will und mir eine lungenentzündung wurde
dann ist das meine freie entscheidung
ist mein problem ist wieder ziemlich
doof aber es ist mein körper das ist
meine sache und wir haben hier erlebt
dass ein staat und das ist doch der der
witz an der sache dass ein staat der ein
staatliches gesundheitswesen propagiert
der sich darum kümmert der dafür steuern
einsammeln um dieses gesundheitswesen
hin zu stellen sagt ach mensch wir haben
nicht genug vorgesorgt wir sind nicht
leistungsfähig genug und weil wir nicht
leistungsfähig genug sind weil wir das
geld für andere sachen ausgegeben haben
kriegst du jetzt zusätzlich noch einen
finanziellen schaden oder im übrigen
auch einen gesundheitlichen schaden
infolge der lok daums und den trägst du
auch noch das ist pervers das ist das
gegenteil des staatsverständnis ist dass
die vielen väter und wenigen mütter des
grundgesetzes hatten das ist das ist das
kernproblem und wir sind jetzt immer
noch nicht dabei dass wir tatsächlich
mal evaluieren was an schäden
angerichtet wurde durch den ganzen
iranischen quad und warum das geschehen
ist ich habe als abgeordneter seiner
zeit immer wieder versucht die vorlagen
zu bekommen mit denen der senat auf
seine tollen verordnungsebene kamen ja
warum das gefährlich sein soll in ein
auto geschäft zu gehen aber nicht
gefährlich im fahrradladen geschehen und
sonstige unfug so der habe ich nie
bekommen man hat sich einfach der
demokratischen kontrolle entzogen ich
mich hat er hand und zwar dauerhaft
erschüttert die erfahrung dieser
pandemie
dass die übergroße mehrheit der menschen
ohne sich zu rühren zugesehen hat wie
die nicht geimpften diskriminiert und
vom leben ausgeschlossen worden sind und
zwar über lange zeit obwohl sie sich für
den beruf für das büro oder da wo sie
gearbeitet haben die werkstatt täglich
haben testen lassen müssen die waren im
prinzip
nachgewiesen gesünder als diejenigen die
vor dem viertel oder halben jahr geimpft
worden sind und nicht mehr untersucht
worden sind aber man hat sie
ausgeschlossen
und das hat niemanden irritiert da ist
auch niemand aufgestanden hatte dazu
geht das nicht ganz wenige ich wir haben
hier hat einmal dazu gehört ich habe
auch dazu gehört aber das war völlig
irrelevant
und das hat mir gezeigt dass in dieser
gesellschaft
ich sage jetzt mal fast alles wieder
möglich ist aber ich glaube man genau
das wäre es nämlich ein faktor den man
glaube ich wirklich nicht unterschätzen
darf ist massenpsychologie und zwar also
ich will überhaupt jetzt nicht sagen
dass es so gewesen ist aber wenn jemand
es inszeniert hätte hätte er es nicht
besser tun können wo kommt dieses
daneben gehen hin her als wir deutschen
offenbar ja ist das toll finden wenn man
dann unser
gerne regeln ob sie sinnvoll sind oder
nicht
aber es ist weit verbreitet und sehe ich
dann gehen wenn das tollste war in dem
düsseldorfer brauer aus da sitzen sie
einem tisch ohne maske natürlich trinken
bier und lachen und sobald sie sich auf
den einsamen weg auf die toilette
begeben müssen sind wasser aufsetzen das
lässt nun offensichtlich keine sinnvolle
regeln und trotzdem wollte sie
durchgesetzt und trotzdem man sich alle
dran gehalten also ein stück weit das
war nämlich die allgemeine
verunsicherung auch aber da braucht man
geld so weiß wie orie jung aber mal zu
hinterfragen macht es wirklich sinn wer
glaube ich stolzer erhalten die politik
daraus gelernt jetzt so der hat den
politik daraus nicht gelernt auch gerade
mit blick auf das was wir heute wieder
gehört haben vom gesundheitsminister und
was möglicherweise in den nächsten
wochen noch kommt also ob die politik
daraus gelernt hat das möchte ich sehr
bezweifeln also ich glaube auch dass die
personen die dazu beigetragen haben
panik zu machen zu machen natürlich
jetzt schlecht sagen können da haben wir
wohl fehler gemacht weil damit
diskreditieren sie sich selbst auf
gewisse art aber vielleicht noch mal
zurück zu diesem thema also ich glaube
man darf nicht unterschätzen die
massenpsychologie da stattgefunden hat
das am anfang war immer die rede von dem
neuartigen neuartigen virus wo man
dachte da kommt jetzt das monster wir es
aus asien dann kursierten irgendwelche
videos wohl menschen plötzlich auf der
straße umfallen in china und dann ich
glaube das war ganz entscheiden kann die
bilder aus bergamo und da wurde
sozusagen wenn man jetzt mal den
menschen wirklich als tier betrachtet da
wurde das system nämlich die amygdala
sowas von aktiviert horror schrecklich
särge die sich stapeln und da geht da
kommt man auch irgendwann gar nicht mehr
mit fakten dagegen an um einfach mal zu
sagen in italien wird normalerweise
irgendwer befinden kann der
feuerbestattung statt und da war auf
einmal eine neue vorschrift eingeführt
worden die krematorien war nicht darauf
vorbereitet und auf einmal stapeln sich
natürlich die sage aber da sitzt die
angst schon im knochen bricht in jeder
faser des körpers und ich glaube da das
da sozusagen alle erfasst wurden von von
einem jahr von den botschaften die
stellen sich ständig auf sie
einprasselten und vor allem die bilder
ich glaube die bilder haben sozusagen
den den nährboden dafür bereitet dass
man nachher dann nur noch dachte
hoffentlich werden leute wie herr wie la
vie ersparen wissen was sie tun das sind
ja die experten gut dass ich die
entscheidungen nicht treffen muss und
dann hat man sich ergeben man hat sich
sozusagen ergeben hat versucht sich
möglichst gut durch zu manövrieren durch
die maßnahmen und ich glaube dann noch
einmal ganz kurz in der in dem moment
weil sie auch gerade über das thema
bildersprache nein man muss sich ganz
kurz unterbrechen denn wir müssen eine
kurze pause machen aber ich wollte die
darauf hinweisen dass wir gleich
natürlich weiter diskutiert es gibt zwei
weitere spaß es geht einmal um das thema
und kleine um das thema waffenlieferung
und wir werden klären was dieser
stimmzettel mit berlin zu tun hat und
warum die ganze spd vor ihm zittern
danke
[Musik]
also da kann ich einen lauten und nicht
ernst nehmen als sogenannten experten
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren bei 485 köpfen fünf meinungen
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt ärgert freut oder
schockiert
[Musik]
so nicht privat jet ski zirkus liberta
ist aber niemand von den politischen
parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur freiheit diese
grün-roten der damen führen hochtrabende
debatten über die rettung des weltklimas
und kommen die füße russland die ratten
das thema ist viel zu wichtig um es nur
der ard zu überlassen lasst den leuten
noch mal einen spaß wir sehen da etwas
was eigentlich fatale ist in der politik
bei den journalisten deren job ist es
doch gerade abweichende meinungen zu
führen und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig gerufen
doch das ist übliche an dem radträger
ausgeschrieben in bewegung bringen ich
habe mein beifahrer eine sache immer
bekommt er kümmert sich darum niemand
ist da die hebel den anderen ist er ganz
klein auch darüber sprechen dass ein tag
nicht fertig richtig wo ist die aufgabe
von journalismus einfach die
verlautbarungen der politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
diskussionen müssten viele meine damen
und herren wir sehen zurück bei viertel
nach acht tolle gäste hier in der runde
thomas geisel ist da cornelia stolze
hans ulrich jörges und marcel gute wir
haben schon diskutiert über corona über
affen pocken und es geht weiter es geht
weiter mit berlin ist geht weiter mit
diesem corpus delicti möchte ich fast
sagen dass der stimmzettel zur
landtagswahl zur senatswahl vergangenen
herbst das war der tag an dem der
bundestag gewählt wurde in ganz
deutschland und in dem an diesem tag
wurde in berlin ebenfalls ein neues
abgeordnetenhaus gewählt und sie
erinnern sich vielleicht daran dass es
noch mehr so überall eigentlich um 18
uhr den gongschlag gab und die
wahllokale in ganz deutschland schlossen
fast in ganz deutschland in berlin
durfte weiter gewählt werden weil es
zahlreiche pannen gegeben hat marcel ute
ihr thema für den heutigen abend das
wahl-debakel das wahlchaos aus berlin
von berlin ende september 20 21 das
wahlchaos dass sich ja bereits auch im
vorfeld abgezeichnet hatte dass das darf
man nicht vergessen weil ihr hinterher
erzählt wurde ja da also niemand konnte
damit rechnen dass dieses und jenes
nicht funktioniert man ist zunächst
einmal hingegangen wissend dass wir eine
bundestagswahl eine landtagswahl und
eine kommunalwahl am gleichen tag haben
fluss einen volksentscheid muss das ist
das nicht schon mal gegeben hat das hat
sich glaubt 94 auch schon mal gegeben in
berlin das war also händelbar damals
sondern hat gleichzeitig auch noch ein
marathon auf den tag gelegt das war
schon per se nicht sonderlich sinnvoll
dann war man offensichtlich nicht in der
lage ist tatsächlich mal so zu
organisieren dass die wahlzettel auch am
tag so wie sich das gehört
beziehungsweise am vortag ausgegeben
werden an die leiter der wahllokale und
das ist idealerweise auch noch die
richtigen stimmzettel für das jeweilige
wahllokal sind dass sie also auch den
kandidaten die nicht auf dem plakat
gesehen hat wählen kann auch das war ein
bisschen schwierig und dann hatten wir
das größte logistische probleme die
sache mit den wagen möglicherweise kennt
jeder berliner dass es so viel bis zum
wallonen pro wahllokal jetzt aber weil
es ja ganz so dramatisch war stichwort
pandemie man muss das mit dem richtigen
trainer in der stimme sagen dramatische
pandemie
man dann nicht mehr sondern weniger
nämlich im schnitt 2 und das führte dann
dazu dass wir stundenlange
warteschlangen vor den wahllokalen
hatten was wiederum natürlich ein
völliger eingriff in die freiheit und
gleichheit der wahl ist weil dann eben
halt jemand mit 85 gehörten einen
menschen mit 93 der sich bei uns
gemeldet hat der sich mehrfach
angestellt so und konnte dann eben halt
nicht wählen weil er dann irgendwann auf
einer stunde mal wieder nach hause gehen
musste und dann kamen wir irgendwann
nach 18 uhr an und da hat man mir jetzt
ist aber auch zu spät es dürften also
auch menschen die ein wahlrecht haben
nicht wählen auf der anderen seite haben
wir eine staatliche versicherung
vorgelegt von menschen die gewählt haben
obwohl sie nicht wählen durften den man
einfach mal die falschen stimmzettel
gegeben hat und dann haben wir das ist
noch mal mein liebling eigentlich war
das zu viel sagt darüber wie diese stadt
hier geführt wird dann haben wir die
vielen menschen die dänen demokratie und
politik so wichtig ist dass sie sogar
noch aus dem grabe gewählt haben wir
haben einen großen teil von menschen die
stimmzettel beziehungsweise erstmal
wahlbenachrichtigungen bekommen haben
die längst verstorben sind und
irgendjemand hat ihr dann offensichtlich
mal genutzt rifaat unterlagen bestellt
und dann haben wir ja diesen tollen
demokratischen kontrolle prozess dann
kontrolliert der der entsprechende
wahlvorstand kontrolliert dann eben halt
ob dieses ding auch von den menschen
unterschrieben ist blöderweise kenne ich
aber herrn meier müller schulz ja
überhaupt nicht so und dann ist da eben
halte krakelt runter dann werde ich den
falschen da ein und schon haben wir
leute die gewählt haben und der grund
warum wir so viele tote haben die
tatsächlich noch benachrichtigt werden
ist liegt im klaren berliner problem das
in der finanzausgleich wenn wir das
wirklich mal anders bereinigen würden
wäre die stadt schon wieder um auch
einige zehntausend leute ärmer im
länderfinanzausgleich und deswegen war
das auch ungünstig und dementsprechend
als das alles zusammenkam und dazu auch
als ist man noch eine vielzahl von
anderen merkwürdigkeiten die am wahltag
passiert sind auch wallonen die
zwischenzeitlich mal geöffnet wurden um
schon mal so ein bisschen voraus zu
zählen gegen 15 uhr und all solche
dönekes habe ich eben halt die wahl als
erster seiner zeit angefochten und habe
das sowohl vor dem
landesverfassungsgerichtshof als auch
vor dem wahlprüfungsausschuss des
deutschen bundestages mit knapp 40 kann
hat ja heute der bundeswahlleiter
in einer ausschusssitzung das war
kommentiert im deutschen bundestag
gesagt also in mindestens sechs
stimmbezirken in berlin müsse zumindest
die bundestagswahl nachgeholt werden und
daraus leitet war in berlin dann auch ab
das würde bedeuten natürlich müssen die
ganze landtagswahl in berlin auch
wiederholt werden und jürgen erstmal die
frage wie lange haben sie an gestanden
an dem wahlsonntag gegend die unter sehr
früh hingegangen in einem wahllokal war
ich auch gleich drin hab gewählt und bin
da raus gegangen das heißt ich habe
alles was danach gekommen ist erstaunt
zur kenntnis genommen aber bei mir lief
auch die der der marathon vorbei da war
mir schon klar hier kommt ja noch
niemand mehr durch um irgendwelche
wahlzettel hin zu fahren oder so das
jahr 2015 war der marathon allerdings
auch bei basis tags ja das alleine ist
es ja aber da gab es keinen apa sda es
war zu wenig stimmzettel in den in den
wahllokalen da muss noch welche hin
transportiert werden das ging eben dann
alles nicht also einmal klar zu machen
was da passiert es einen solchen ball
skandal hat es in deutschland noch nie
gegeben und trotzdem ist es jetzt acht
monate her hat weder das
landesverfassungsgericht noch der
wahlprüfungsausschuss des bundestags
bestimmtes muss neu gewählt werden das
hängt immer noch acht monate
und wenn die jetzt noch ein paar monate
darüber beraten es gibt ja auch kein
interesse man muss es ja mal sagen also
die regierende koalition in berlin die
kann ja der rot grüne senat kann ja gar
kein interesse an einer neuwahl
aber vielleicht zwei vielleicht sogar
ihr amt verlieren dass er natürlich
haben die grünen könnten die nächste
regierung die bürger noch ist aber ganz
klar die spd hat keinen der den ich aber
das gericht selbst hatte übrigens
gericht selbst hat ein interesse denn es
werden keine neuen richter nach berufen
durch ein parlament was möglicherweise
gar nicht korrekt berufen worden ist
dann ist auch die richterwahl wieder zum
teufel das heißt die hängen da selber
dran alles was parlamente so tun hängt
an dieser entscheidung und ich finde
nach acht monaten die vorstellung dass
in dem landesparlament von berlin
menschen sitzen die gar nicht gewählt
worden sind die da nicht rein gehören
und andere die eigentlich rein gehören
draußen bleiben müssen es doch ohne
erträge thomas kneisel das hätte auch in
düsseldorf ganz genauso passieren können
oder nicht das ist um es mal klar zu
sagen das ist zynismus nachgerade also
jedem darauf ist er meiner führung von
düsseldorf wäre es nicht was sagen sie
jetzt
gut mehr als eben so sagen es gab bei
der kommunalwahl mit dem hohen briefwahl
anteil da gab es auch ein paar probleme
in der tat dass ein paar
briefe eben nicht mehr rechtzeitig
angekommen sind
wir reden über ganz andere dimensionen
wobei ich in der tat sagen musste wenn
hier die wahl angefochten wird dann muss
das gericht darüber entscheiden das ist
dann letztlich eine frage ob die wahl
tatsächlich rechtmäßig verfassungsgemäß
zustande gekommen ist und wenn das nicht
der fall ist wo der muss man natürlich
sich überlegen wie man kann ja nicht die
wahl für nichtig erklären denn das würde
bedeuten dass all das was von dem
parlament das in der wahl gewählt wurde
beschlossen wurde noch nicht da erst
wobei auch nicht lange und muss sagen da
ist es ja üblich dass das
verfassungsgericht sagt wenn bestimmte
regelungen nicht verfassungsgemäß sind
dann setzt man eine frist für eine
neuregelung und hebt sozusagen nicht die
vergangenheit auf also angemessen
natürlich wenn wenn die anfechtung
erfolgreich ist dann muss es nicht eine
wiederholung der wahl sondern eine
frühzeitige neuwahl geben dass eben
tatsächlich im ergebnis einer dann
hoffentlich regulären wahl 1 1 besser
sagen legitimiertes parlament zustande
komme das problem ist doch so wenn ich
neuwahlen beziehungsweise eine
wahlwiederholung bekomme dann bekomme
ich die deshalb weil ich sage dass
diesem parlament diesen 19 abgeordnete
aus wie es jetzt zusammen sitzt die
demokratische legitimation fehlt weil
das nicht aus freien gleichen und
geheimen wahlen hervorgegangen ist und
wenn ich also dann ein salopp gesagt
räuber parlament habe das irgendwie da
plötzlich sitzt dann kann ich doch nicht
sagen einerseits seid ihr nicht
demokratisch legitimiert und müsste
deshalb weg aber macht noch mal ein
bisschen weiter ich hatte das in meiner
anfechtung auch in dem ich habe ja
damals auch vor dem
bundesverfassungsgericht eine
einstweilige anordnung beantragt zu
verhindern dass dieses 19
abgeordnetenhaus sich konstituiert bis
die vorwürfe aufgeklärt sei ja auch kein
problem wir hatten ja ein parlament das
achtzehnte abgeordnetenhaus das
unstreitig dem saarland was jetzt aber
dazu sagen nicht demokratisch
legitimiert ist und ob das jetzt noch
mal ein halbes jahr länger arbeitet oder
nicht ist ja nicht schlimm der des 19
sie verliert ja nichts die
legislaturperiode dauert dann ja auch
wieder fünf jahre so hält das
verfassungsgericht voller stolz hält
eigentlich
jemand rein marktbeobachterin als
wählerin die jetzt nicht direkt in
demokratische prozesse eingreifen weil
sie nicht abgeordnete waren aber wie
wirkt das auf sie wenn sie das sehen
hören was hier in berlin passiert ist
und aber auch den streit unter
politikern dazu mitbekommen also ich
finde das auch ein verheerendes signal
das man so schlampig sozusagen mit mit
einem solchen fehler umgeht und sich
dann da weiter durchwursteln und sagst
du na ja in wahrheit jetzt um die blöd
aber gucken wir mal ob eine neuwahl
machen oder nicht und dann sehen wir
weiter ich halte das wirklich für gift
für eine demokratie und aus meiner sicht
ist auch so zu sagen dass das vertrauen
in die demokratie einen rechtsstaat in
den letzten jahren schon an
verschiedenen stellen massiv beschädigt
worden und das führt dazu dass parteien
wie die afd zuwachs zulauf bekommen das
ist die folge von fehlern von spd und
cdu über jahre aus meiner sicht und nur
auf die afg zb einzudreschen finde ich
extrem billig und das führt auch zu
einem ganz großen teil von nichtwählern
also zum beispiel in der nrw wahl wenn
ich mehr als 40 prozent sind überhaupt
nicht so weit gegangen dass die größte
fraktion ist die der nichtwähler und das
ist für eine kleine luke demokratie ein
armuts sind wir in berlin sind wir in
berlin schon so viele pannen desaster
debakel gewöhnt dass es sowas gibt wie
eine ich sag's mal lautet egal stimmung
hier also das ist berlin und das lässt
uns alles gern islam was die öffentliche
verwaltung angeht ist komplett
verschlampt und daran hat man sich über
viele jahre gewöhnt dass regiert ja auch
immer die gleiche koalition weiter die
hat nichts geändert wenn man einen neuen
ausweis braucht also oder einen neuen
pass braucht man ein jahr bis man den
terminen am bürger am krieg sind alles
zu halten alle berlins
bundesverdienstkreuz erklärer leider
fähigkeit ich wollte
hierbleiben sind inzwischen hat das
landesverfassungsgericht ja die
schriftlichen unterlagen von mehr als
wahllokalen
bestellt und bekommen und wenn man da
rein guckt sie kennen die alle ich kenne
nur ein bisschen was davon dann stellt
man fest dass das wird ja immer
schlimmer da durch das sind raus
gerissene seiten das sind kugelschreiber
schmie rage da sind unleserliche notizen
das sind aber auch ein paar sehr
wertvolle dinge die man da ablesen ich
will ein beispiel erzählen in
friedrichshain ein wahllokal morgens um
8 eröffnet um viertel nach acht stellen
sie fest sie haben die falschen
stimmzettel bekommen die rufen bei der
wahlleitung an und sage wir haben die
falschen stimmzettel die sagen ihn gibt
die mal ruhig weiter aus sei es tun sie
in berlin und zwei stunden später kommen
zwei stunden später kriegen sie den
anruf die dürfen sie aber nicht werten
die sind ungültig das heißt das sind die
stimmen von 82 menschen in den mülleimer
geworfen worden ohne dass diese 82
menschen davon was erfahren haben durch
seine unfähigkeit einer wahlfarce leber
durch verlust ist dass die wahl
wiederholt werden muss die landtagswahl
in berlin absolut und hans-georg ist
wird sie wiederholt ja ich bin davon
überzeugt weil das nicht geht ich glaube
sie wird anfang kommenden jahres
wiederholt thomas kaiser wird sie
wiederholt es gibt frühzeitig neuwahlen
deswegen weil dieses wahlergebnis zu
recht angefochten auf stolze und sie
sind auch da man ja also also wir sind
hier der mahnung 15 0 ein stück 100
prozent die frage hier so kann man's
landtagswahl wird wiederholt neu gibt es
auch seine mama ist wahrscheinlicher
bezogen haben soll steht das berliner
wahlrecht irgendwie schon dadurch dass
wir sowohl bezirks als auch landeslisten
bei den parteien haben kriegen sie ein
solches kuddelmuddel weil sie eben die
versionierung unterrichten haben
verändert sich alles durch möchte nur
einen ungefähren lassen verfassung ist
wahrscheinlich nur find es ist in der
tat mich hat das massiv gestört dass das
verfassungsgericht schon nicht
eingegriffen hat beim zusammentreten
dieses 19 abgeordnetenhauses und was
mich jetzt wirklich überrascht hat ist
dass die von der spd nominierte
präsidentin dieses verfassungsgerichts
die frau selting offensichtlich eben
auch kein interesse hat jetzt das
verfahren zu beschleunigen oder auch die
öffentlichkeit herzustellen das
verwaltungsgericht düsseldorf hat vor
jahren entschieden dass
selbstverständlich diese unterlagen
öffentlich sind und
der verfassungsgerichtshof die
präsidentin beklagt sie dass wir diese
unterlagen nun veröffentlichten presse
öffentlich machen das ja wohl ein witz
ja wo ist also das thema wird uns noch
beschäftigen es wird mutmaßlich eine
juni eine entscheidung an na dann ein
wenn man hier leben wolle
es gibt eine vorgezogene neuwahl thomas
geisel sie polarisieren immer wieder mit
beiträgen zur ukraine jetzt geht es um
das thema waffenlieferungen naja also
zunächst mal vorab ich bin kein gegner
des militärs und ich bin kein pazifist
ich bin trotzdem gegen waffenlieferungen
deswegen weil ich der meinung bin sie
sind erstens gefährlich sie sind
kontraproduktiv und sie sind
wahrscheinlich auch unnötig sind
gefährlich deswegen weil glaube ich
einigkeit darüber besteht dass
russland diesen krieg militärisch
jedenfalls nicht verlieren wird oder
will heißen genauer gesagt dass sie
keine diesen krieg militärisch nicht
gewinnen kann weil das liegt einfach
daran dass die russland ist eine
atommacht russland ist natürlich
materielle und keine haushoch überlegen
wenn wir die ukraine jetzt mit allen
waffen versorgen die sie anfordert dann
wird es diesen krieg in die länge ziehen
wir die zerstörung noch größeres ausmaß
annehmen dann wird der blutzoll auf
beiden seiten weiter steigen und das
land zerstört werden die zahl der
flüchtlinge steigen es wird immer
schwieriger werden ich bin auch
ms je gelänge die russen an den rand
einer niederlage
zu bringen dann ist die gefahr glaube
ich nicht von der hand zu weisen dass
ein diktator wladimir putin dem wir
viele realitätsverlust attestieren dass
der in der tat auf den roten knopf
drückt und einen eine taktische
atomwaffen zündet ein szenario das sich
politisch für unverantwortlich halten
würde ich halte es für kontraproduktiv
einfach deswegen auch weil wir müssen ja
sagen was wollen wir den langfristig wir
wollen ja irgendwann eine stabile
friedensordnung haben und die wird in
der ukraine sollte den natürlich platz
greifen ohne dass die territoriale
integrität der ukraine gefährdet wird
dann ist die ukraine aber ein florales
ein ethnisch ein kulturell an
sprachlichen religiös florales land dann
müssen die einzelnen
bevölkerungsteile wieder aufeinander
zugehen können wenn wir jetzt diesen
krieg weiter befeuern dann stellten wir
auf der einen seite und römische
nationalisten auf der anderen seite
russische nationalisten also eine beides
parteien putin der sagte wir stellen die
staatliche oder die die nationale
identität der ukraine in frage es gibt
wie in der ukraine auch leute die das
land in trophy zieren wollen je länger
der krieg dauert desto mehr wird diese
radikalen kräfte gestellt stell mir das
gerade vor wie thomas kreisel mit frau
und fünf kindern in seinem haus von
unten kommen einbrecher wollen also das
wohnzimmer belagern wohl also es ist
erdgeschoss belagert thomas gesagt ich
ziehe mich nach oben im ersten stock
zurück damit die einbrecher nicht noch
weiter vordringen die dringen also
weiter vor und dann räumen sie sozusagen
auch den ersten stock das reisenetz die
einbrecher könnt ihr gerne als ihr
ausland er war selber aufnehmen im wald
über einen koffer liegt keine ausländer
sind davon aus die ukraine stellt die
kampfhandlungen ein und wladimir putin
werde das ganze land erobern glauben sie
wirklich dass putin damit auch den
frieden gewinnen würde ich bin sehr sehr
sicher herr putin hätte so viel freude
an diesem militärischen sieg wie die
amerikaner aber nochmal helga
lokalisieren jemand trinkt in ihr haus
ein und sie sagen sie können ein
haushalt lasse krieg für einige machen
aber das ist doch aber dass dort das
ganz klare argument im gegen
ausgesprochen das hat der eroberer von
der eroberung und ich sage ja ist doch
ganz klar was hat der wie kann der
eindringling sich gegen den in dem ding
der reingeht verteidigen in dem fall in
dem der greise und polizei ruft oder in
dem fall
das ist natürlich die internet
verteidigt wir müssen ansätzen an dem
was ja in minsk zwei auch vorgehen
beiden seiten also heute sicher geld
sich weil es ja auch deswegen
gescheitert weil sich die internationale
gemeinschaft welt zu wenig darum
gekümmert hat man muss
noch die russen ja das ist ein problem
und deswegen rosi runden die ost jetzt
lassen sie uns mal was zu ihrer these
sagen die die ukraine sollen sich also
erobern lassen und dann wie sie sagen
unbewaffnet zur wehr setzen gegen den
erobert ist die alternativ was was
machen die dann die setzen sie auf die
straße und die wie gandhi und sagen an
mir kommt jetzt blockiere der als
alternative ist 3 aber sie haben sie
haben doch als bürgermeister in
düsseldorf zu unrecht einfach unrecht
gelten lassen sondern da hatten sie
polizei und wenn es unrecht gab es doch
die polizei eingeschritten es gab ja in
düsseldorf so hoffe ich zumindest und
mein lasst mich zu erinnern keine
rechtsfreien räume in dem sie gesagt
haben will jemand irgendwas besetzen
wollte das rathaus beispielsweise durfte
das und durfte ein teil ihres
oberbürgermeister büros besetzen und sie
haben gesagt ich gebe ihnen gerne auf
den schreibtischen und damit es bloß
keine gewalt mehr gibt das ist ja ein
wirklich antiquierter ansatz seien
entweder sie davon weltfremd brauchen
doch gar nicht darüber diskutieren dass
das hier doch sie haben gesagt es
bestehe einigkeit dass die männer den
krieg nicht gewinnen kann er sagen sie
dazu
doch wie soll das
einkaufen ist sie würden erstens es
vermutlich halten dass wenn die unserem
investor israel den krieg gewinnt das
die russen kapitulieren und die weiße
fahnen leyen darum geht es auch nicht
einigkeit darüber der einem jahr muss
ich mal sagen sie reden generell von
waffen liefern also gar keine
waffenlieferung auch keine sogenannten
leichten waffen schwere schon mal gar
nicht der ukraine krieg gar keine waffen
um sich zu wehren damit diskreditieren
sie die haltung der spd generell auf
eine dramatische weise das heißt nämlich
sie sind in wahrheit mit dem aggressor
verbündet und wollen ihm stopp mal jetzt
lassen sie mich mal was sagen und machen
ihm den weg frei das ganze land zu
erobern und dann können die
unbewaffneten sich hinterher darum
kümmern wie sie sich wehren gegen die
besatzung ich glaube die die aktuelle
situation ist schon weit über ihre these
hinaus denn es fehlt nicht mehr viel
dass russland den don was also die
ukraine komplett erobert hat so wie es
schon die krim erobert hat und die
landbrücke von der crew nach russland
und dann geht es nur noch um die frage
ist jetzt der punkt erreicht an dem ein
waffenstillstand vereinbart wird um
darüber zu verhandeln ob dieser diese
teilung des landes zwischen großen auch
in mehrheitlich russisch besiedelten
gebieten in der ost ukraine und der west
ukraine mit den europäisch orientierten
die künftige grenzlinie zwischen beiden
staaten ist und das geht natürlich nur
wenn die ukraine in der lage ist sich
gegen die russen zu verteidigen so fehr
die anstalten machen weiter zu
marschieren diese frage stellt sich dann
ein ich glaube sie haben ein punkt ist
in ihrer argumentation nicht
berücksichtigt das ist nämlich der dass
latina putin einem
imbiss sagen ziemlich wahnwitzigen
vorstellungen
gehandelt hat die sich als kapitale
twomblys roasters putin dachte er wird
insbesondere in den gebieten im don was
wo die russen demo die
russischsprachigen bevölkerung mehrheit
hat als befreier empfangen selbst
ein kapitaler ein kapitaler irrtum der
wahrscheinlich seinen ursprung darin
dass wir seit 20 jahren immer nur noch
ja sagen und speichellecker um sich
versammelt dem das sagen was er gerne
hört das hat nicht gesagt deswegen sagte
er kann den frieden gar nicht mehr
gewinnen er lebte er völlig irrsinnigen
vorschlag ein bisschen ähnlich wie die
amerikaner als sie dem irak in
anführungszeichen befreit haben und
deswegen glaube ich werde putin ein
großes interesse daran haben dass eine
lösung zustande kommt die ihnen insofern
das gesicht wahren lässt als seine seine
die russische sprachige minderheit oder
in vielen teilen ist er sogar eine
mehrheit eben autonomierechte bekommt
dass sie ihre sprache weiter ausüben
können das nicht gewundert mit einer
geige
von einem jahr dass sie immer noch
glauben dass ich immer noch das immer
noch spd politiker der meinung sind zu
glauben sie wüssten was wladimir putin
denkt wir haben nun erkannt und das
staatsoberhaupt als ehemaliges
spd-mitglied ist nun das paradebeispiel
dafür dass offenbar gerade in ihrer
partei eine permanente fehleinschätzung
dessen vorherrscht was wladimir putin zu
tun gedenkt und sie machen den gleichen
fehler schon wieder sie gehen schon
wieder davon aus dass wladimir putin
rational sich verhält wie kommen sie
eigentlich dazu zu glauben die ukraine
könne nicht gewinnen und bebra putin
wilder gesichtswahrend raus und würde
mit männer die ganze ukraine besetzt
probleme haben dieses land zu befrieden
und überhaupt aber das alles wird wie
kommen sie eigentlich zu diesen ganzen
anderen wo doch erkennbar alles was die
spd oder viele spd-politiker bisher über
wladimir putin gesagt getan und mit ihm
zusammen ausgegangen haben alles völlig
falsch ist wie größten fehler hat auch
die cdu gemacht mit einer kanzlerin
merkel und nicht so sehr die spd das zum
einen was mich stört was mich
unglaublich stört in diesen debatten die
ja immer wieder da geführt werden ist
der gratis mut der menschen die alles
sagt janisch und jetzt geht es hier
richtig in den krieg jetzt mal los
allesamt ab an die front bitte dann
schickt du deine söhne zuerst das ist
das ist das meer ruhig mal das tun sie
um kramer nicht wir die ukrainer sagen
wir gehen an die front wird diskutiert
doch keiner dass er an die front will
wir sehen dass die ukraine sich wehren
und fahrzeug zwei rehe und von privaten
von deutschland hatte enttäuschte die
mannschaft wach ich geben treffen mir
und nicht die ukraine es ist einige
rinder schafe in der hat doch was würde
ich schon auch kokolores es geht
zunächst einmal um die frage ganz
nüchtern betrachtet was erreicht man mit
einem solchen konflikt und was kann man
verlieren was man erreicht auf jeden
fall ist die tatsache dass mit jeder
ausgefallenen ernte in der ukraine der
hunger in der welt dramatisch wird auch
das muss berücksichtigt werden bei
diesem gratis und ja ich möchte nur dass
man ein russisches mähdrescher auf die
wiesen fahren das ist doch unmöglich
immer so und aus weil eine diplomatische
sollten sie am meisten entsetzt mich
dass menschen wie sie auf die russische
propaganda mit atomwaffen
fallen die ist erkennbar für den westen
in den von herrn lang auf dem ich muss
leider hübner auf ihre erdball damit ist
schluss von konsolidierungs ganz hessen
und muss sein spannend war weil es so
temperamentvoll mal diese runde ich hier
beenden bedanke mich ganz herzlich bei
thomas kaiser cornelia stolze hans
ulrich jörges und bei marcel ute sage
ganz ganz herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen
bis morgen abend auf wiedersehen
[Musik]